hello I'm the Nostalgia good guy
remember it so you don't have to with a
certain themed month coming up in
December and that certain theme
containing a lot of directed DVDs
sequels ah I figure it only makes sense
to talk about a certain aspect of those
sequels you see in the late 90s and
early 2000s Disney struck a big issue
with their directed DVD singles for
whatever reason kids really want to know
what happened after happily ever after
you name it Cinderella to Pocahontas -
even Hunchback of Notre 'adam - ooh
maybe now we finally get the original
book ending despite some of them being
given an impressive animation budget
almost on par with their theatrical
hand-drawn movies most of them are known
as some of the worst material Disney's
put out who was really asking for
another Brother Bear who couldn't sleep
at night if they didn't know what
happened to crocks groove looking these
over though I did start to wonder which
Disney sequels did we want to see which
ones could actually be explored more and
we'd welcome another film about some of
these are already in demand and being
made like wreckit-ralph Incredibles and
so on but we're also getting cars 3 in
Toy Story 4 after cars 2 and monsters
University so not as likely that these
are gonna happen but I thought be fun to
explore the Disney sequels that we
actually wanted to see in fact my first
choice isn't even a part - it's a part 3
to maybe make up for parts of part 2 I'm
talking about Fantasia the first film is
seen by many as an artistic masterpiece
and it was meant to continue with a ton
of varying sequels well sadly we only
got one with Fantasia 2000 which not
only did poorly at the box office but it
kind of pissed off those who loved the
first film with edited versions of the
music slightly more childish segments
and painful painful cameos fraud
dismemberment ripoff Oh
you can figure out their target audience
when they've referred to Salvador Dali
as the melting watch guy now Salvador
Dali you know the limp watches guy yeah
I can really see him doing something
similar in the first film Leonardo da
Vinci you know one of the ninja turtles
but still it had some beautiful moments
and exceptional animation and ideas so
maybe a third one could work if they
just knocked off talking down to the
audience when the first Fantasia failed
to make the money it needed back they
worked in the other segments they were
gonna put into future Fantasia's into
just short cartoons the same thing
happened with Fantasia 2000 which gave
us two wonderful segments Salvador
Dali's oh sorry I mean melting watch
guys destino and a heartbreaking
rendition of the little match girl
both of these are phenomenal and give
hope that maybe a third Fantasia could
happen if they're risky but also adult
enough to pull it off it's definitely
worth taking that chance but not all
Disney sequels have to be a dolt
how about Robin Hood this was about as
basic an action-adventure movie you
could get but it did it so wonderfully
it was creative exciting heck rate
action scenes and one of the few Disney
films that was entirely animal morphic
life-forms no humans could exist in this
world with Zootopia being such a big hit
he'll maybe they'll guess equal to
perhaps another one of these would be a
lot of fun
everything seems kind of laid out Robin
Hood and Maid Marian are married maid
Hood they have a babysitter living with
them who's also a baby I never got that
part but they could have kids and they
could go on to ventures to just create
another evil to fight and this could be
a very simple but also very enjoyable
adventure animation especially has come
a long way it'd be really cool to see
these with much smoother lines as
opposed to that sketchiness and maybe
even given the CG route again they made
them look great in Zootopia
could probably work here too it seems
like the possibilities are strong enough
to check out and speaking of animal
movies why not the Great Mouse Detective
the film wasn't a huge hit when it came
out but it's getting more and more of a
following its hero basil of Baker Street
is uncontrollably likable he's funny
he's smart he's got a ton of energy and
he's incredibly enjoyable to watch
granted his arch-nemesis rhadigan who's
also a fantastic character is killed in
the end but so what the stories of basil
obviously have an influence from
sherlock holmes hell he stays in
sherlock holmes's walls and sherlock had
more enemies than just Moriarty so why
can't basil
the ending even indicates he's starting
a new mystery why don't we just pick up
where that left off a missing ring okay
well who took it for what diabolical
plan maybe it's part of some other
villains big scheme and Dawson to his
new assistant has to get used to Basil's
eccentric nature there's ideas here
maybe he can even be solving a crime
while Sherlock is solving one parallel
to his come on there was a cool clock
tower seen on the last one we can go
even bigger even more exciting look into
it disney there's something cool here
now a lot of Disney animated films are
based on books and the book has a sequel
shouldn't the movie too I'm of course
talking about Alice in Wonderland now I
know what you're thinking come on that
first film is perfect leave it alone
don't add any more to what was fine but
here's the thing there's so many
versions of Alice in Wonderland out
there many of them trying to be lying
for lie the definitive version and some
of them not even getting the title right
but out of all that Disney's is still
the best because they knew it had to be
a movie first and they had to change
things around to make it flow like one
but with that said that means there's
still a ton of things left out
characters like the Jabberwocky the
Griffon the knight there's a ton of
places you can go with this and because
the narrative is not very story based
and more of a person just coming across
strange thing after strange thing you
don't even have to worry that much about
the story just focus on the surrealism
the imagination the humor all the fun
stuff that made the first film so cool
you can make through the looking-glass
actually like through the looking-glass
unlike through the looking-glass even
the original voice actress Katherine
Bowman is still alive and she still
reenact her role it seems silly not to
make this all the pieces are right there
don't give it a complicated story about
prophecies or Narnia robots just do mad
people acting like mad people and you'll
have something great come on
this makes too much crazy sense not to
happen
but it doesn't just have to be one of
the hand-drawn movies the CG movies are
perfectly eligible - with all the
sequels Pixar says they're bringing out
I'm surprised there's no interest in
another inside out not only was the
first film incredibly poignant as well
as funny but the ideas were literally
mind-blowing when growing up there's so
many changes that happen that can be
more than just a puberty joke maybe some
emotions get more powerful and become
bullies maybe some other people's
emotions multiply and start taking over
her emotions I mean come on other
people's emotions can have an effect on
others I mean why not have them like
sneak into another person's brains and
emotions and like try to take over maybe
even brand new emotions are born new
characters the possibilities are endless
apparently when making this movie there
were even more ideas the filmmakers
wanted to utilize but they didn't have
the time another movie showing Riley
growing up in dealing with these new
emotions is a perfect way to explore oh
it makes more sense in cars three you
for God's sake do me a favor Pixar don't
keep a closed mind on this one but
that's not the only Pixar film how about
Monsters Inc let me explain I'm sure
you're thinking of the follow-up film
monsters University has counted first of
all that was a prequel not a sequel
second what the hell want to see that
what little kid is saying mommy I want
to see these monsters go to a degree
granting institution for higher learning
no one but you know what would be
interesting maybe Sully continues to see
Boo and watches her as she grows up
maybe as a teen or an adult she starts
to question whether or not she should
still be communicating with
quote-unquote monsters in the closet
maybe she tries to convince herself
they're not real and that creates a rift
between her and Sully maybe all those
existential issues that always sneak
their way into Pixar films can have an
explosion of self conflict here who
wouldn't want to see a girl grow up
talking to literal monsters and how it
affects her and the people around her
it's sensible it's strange it's childish
it's adult
it's a neat idea damn it it's a neat
idea I don't see a PG rated version of
Animal House I have the r-rated version
for that but the Pixar's love of talking
about growing up and moving on with
things this seems like
the perfect format for that but it's not
like animation reality always went hand
in hand we'll get in chanted an animated
Disney peasants into the real world only
to find out she's not looking for a
prince but instead a reasonable
relationship it was a cute famine did
well the box office but that does beg
the question what about the prince and
the woman he takes to the animated realm
most of the movie was showing how an
animated heroine reacted to the real
world but how about how a real heroine
reacts to the animated world this
character didn't get much focus in the
original and now that kids know she was
played by Elsa Disney's probably kicking
themselves for that so here's your
chance to expand on that character
doesn't he have fun mocking its old
tropes with this but how about their
newer tropes now not all Disney films
are Snow White or Sleeping Beauty we got
our mulan's and our Hunchback of Notre
Dom's and such how fun would it be to
see this character try to survive in
that kind of animate world she can teach
them about reality and they can teach
her about whimsical magic and such it
could be pretty enjoyable maybe there's
something here something that can be
explored more okay probably nothing
fantastic but like you dive into the
other side of things it could be worth
looking into in fact a lot of these are
worth looking into
with so many Disney sequels that none of
us ever want to watch maybe we can start
looking at the ones that we do want to
watch I mean yes in the long run I want
to see new material like a lot of people
do we have enough repeats in the world
but if you're gonna do sequels anyway
and they're just gonna keep making money
maybe give these a thought I'm not
saying they'll be great but they gotta
be better than a lot of the ones that we
got in the past Disney this is
definitely worth looking into
I know it's a long shot even dream
worthy but there's anything you tried to
teach us is that dreams can definitely
come true
I've been nostalgic red can you excuse
me there's a certain holiday I need to
get ready for
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing prevent
child abuse prevention abuse America was
founded in 1972 it is the first
organization in the United States whose
sole mission is to prevent the abuse and
neglect of our nation's children it
undertakes its mission by effecting
change at the governmental and community
level on the systems that support the
full range of services needed to promote
the child development process and
provide parents with better conditions
based in Chicago PCA America has state
chapters in 47 states and over 400
healthy families America sites in 41
states together approximately 500 staff
in the national office
and chapters managed over 353 different
locally based strategies to meet their
mission of the organization they have an
additional 2,900 home visitation workers
supervisors and program managers to
oversee and implement this program so
much good has come from this
organization and if you look at their
website or their YouTube page you can
see all the lives they helped to make
better click on the link below and see
how YouTube can help so many children
have the childhood they deserve